معنى من
كيفكو مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
اهلا ااه بك معنا كيف يمكن التعليق على
كلام ااا السكرتاير مجلس الامن القومي
والدفاع الاوكراني اوكسيداني لوف الذي قال
ان بلاده ان بلادكم تلقت عروضا للدخول في
التسويه على الطريقه الكوريه همم هل هذا
ممكن ان يطرح على الطاوله
مساء الخير
شكرا
لكم لان العربيه كالعاده يعني كله اخباركم
وبحوث عميقه وتفصاليه
شكرا لك اهلا وسهلا فيك هذا واجبنا تفضل
سيد رئيس مجلس الامن الاوكراني هيك كان
جوابه على كثير من الاسئله
الاوكرانيه بطريقه كوريه تمام
اوكرانيا من قسمه
للشبهين يعني شبه شمالي او شرقي والغرب
كبيره
320 يوم من الحرب
التي يعني يمكن ان تقدمها اوكرانيا بهذا
التوقيت بالذات خاصه مع اشتداد المعارك
يعني
منذ قليل مسؤول عسكري امريكي يتحدث عن
معارك وحشيه تحصل في منطقه بخموت وهجوم
جديد على سوليدار
كل واحد بيعرف
باس مناطق مهمه جدا
يعني ممتاز جدا اللي تستخدم في فولاذ والى
اخره وكمان
الاراضي من تقدم باس محافظه
غنيه
خام الحديد
باليوتيوب يوتيوب
اللي بيحصلوا على اليوتيوب وعلى الكره
الارضيه
وتستخدم
لانتاج بطاريات حديثه للسيارات ولطيرات
والاخريه وفي اوكرانيا من اكبر مناجم على
فكره في العالم
يعني هناك امر واقع عسكري همم
تعترف الدول اخرى مستقبلا همم وقد تحجب
عنهم سلاح وقد تضعكم امام واقع جديد
فبالتالي ستضرون امام شوح المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه امام شحال السلاح ان تسلم
ولو بوقف اطلاق نار وليس بتوقيع على
الاستلام او على حل شامل الي والا لماذا
يمكن ان يطرح مثل هكذا فكره ولو كان ردا
على سؤال من قبل احد بمنصب سيدنا لوف
للاسف الشديد وفق لنتائج السنه الماضيه
اوكرانيا خسرت تقريبا 30% من ناتج الداخلي
مش معقوله ولو مش مساعده
لخلفائنا والجيراننا فكان من المستحيل ان
همم
شوفوا الخارطه العالميه روسيا اكبر من
اوكرانيا ب 38 مره مساحتا هي ذبيحه او جثه
يعني اربع مرات اكبر في عدد السكان طبعا
تفوق في عسكري واقتصادي والاخره ولو مش
مصادر
ماديه وعسكريه وتاييد العسكريه من الغرب
من اصدقائنا الجيراننا من ذلك وبعزيمه
الاوكرانيين ايضا ولكن لذلك البعض يقول
بانه اذا توقف ذلك او خف ستضطرون امام
الامر الواقع الى القبول بضم هذه المناطق
على الاقل مقابل تنازل روسيا عن تعرض لكل
اوكرانيا
الحرب
روسيا لا تزداد تحت تقريبا
مساحه من الاراضي وكرانيه اللي تعادل
مساحه الامارات المتحده تتصور لماذا هذا
القرن 19 18 او قرن 21 اولا والثانيه همم
نحن لا نريد اراضي الغير لا ابدا ابدا
لذلك تعرض اراضي الاخرين للخطر عندما
اردتم ان تنضموا الى الناتو والى الاتحاد
الاوروبي شعره روسيا بالخطر لذلك يعني
البعض يقول انه لاعب دور الضحيه من قبل
اوكرانيا لا ينفعها دائما لانها ايضا
تصرفت بطريقه انانيه بالنسبه اليها بينما
كان في امكانها ان تفاوض الروس وان تجلس
معهم على الطاوله لكي تمنع ان يتحكم الغرب
وامريكا على راسهم بمصير اوكرانيا واوروبا
زي ما يقولون العرب
يسرى
على فكره كان هدف من ارداف
لبدء الهجوم الروسي ضد اوكرانيا المقلد
بانهم
يخافون اوكرانيا سوف تندم الى خلف
ابدا
كانت حديث في اوكرانيا
فقط
روسيا ستغسل هذه السنه
1300 كيلو متر مباشره يعني حدود مع دول
حلف اطلس في الجدد النتيجه